no ragazzi dove è morto gandal ma è vero
è vero sono due facce
ciao
lo zio addio di mazzarri è da tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti questo video sono
farisei oggi sono con la spazzola è con
sasha sera come ti faccio anche il
macaco az ok
quello è un marchio buona buona visione
buona visione
famiglie questa porta si è aperta sasha
aperta anzi aperta anzi esistono diversi
che però spera con ricordi c'è una
fessura corri corri corri corri corri
sasha corri corri corri seguimi corri
corri corri corri corri veloce veloce
c'è una fessura profilati entro la
fessura premi e quando arrivi premi e
veloce velocissimo dolcissimo bravo
bravo bravo bravo cazzo bravo questo
voleva e ora dovremo in teoria salvare
la partita perché non ho idea di dove
cazzo siamo noi non siamo più case
giando questa è una caverna incredibile
che ma se uno ci stiamo addentrando
troppo perché vedo della luce estivo in
starlight vado festa ieri
cos'è questa roccia un ponte spiegami
che cazzo di nora d'acqua e dove è morto
gandal ma è vero è vero
oddio sul tetto che ho vissuto in mano
c'è il drago lui portò ghiandoni che
uguale o dalle miniere di myra di moira
orfei
allora vediamo di guardare ma può
scendere si può scendere da due parti
c'è l'acqua come questo ti faccio una
strada sasha voi scendere quando era per
la strada poi sento ora in cui i rumori
bruttissimi c'è un'altra porta il cac
merda c'è un indigeno sempre un
individuo o cacchio
il normale ma è infatti gigante era uno
di quelli che ucciso prima e vorrei
erano prontissimi
se non altro un altro attenzione la
fetta come un aspettato un bravi segnale
facciamo così guarda mi monimo questa è
un accetta io gli do fuoco gli do fuoco
così ma cosa fai ti sta andando dal di
non si sa mai che si svegliano così
almeno vediamo di più primo e secondo
diamo fuoco alla gente che picchiano
guarda allora fa in europa vieni qua
guardi il cielo in disegno in casa da
una porta a miglia che se lei poi olaf
in faccia da file ha preso fuoco questo
non muore provvederò gli aspetti amore
non perde denti ok allora guarda una
roba però preme reciso sto coso di vista
ti fa la stessa roba lì è un duplicatore
di ascia per soli brenda larry e
rimetterla premici dal vero sì non so
perché duplica le asce ma si può
duplicare anche il cibo tipo gesù cristo
abbiamo insieme vai poker tour a [ __ ]
bastard
corri sasha karlic social
penso che sia arrivato il fermo non è
arrivata una è arrivata una arrivato a
pavia accendere anche aspetta farmi
mangiare [ __ ] che cos'è allora io un
piano b in teoria alla ci viene addosso
quel tizio ci buttiamo nell'acqua come
gand al nono zii ammazziamo lo come e
lancio un flare fermo ma non ce la fai è
troppo forte
avevamo la dinamica l'altra volta è zio
e ascolto st vieni tu vieni preso di
mira io l'ho attacco alle spalle to
proteggiti con il tasto quello destro
che ti pari
ok spiegami un attimo perché c'è
l'albero tipo avatar associati h che è
quello di prima aia e quello che
rossissima che si ammazzano questo
attenzione sasha ci ha preso di mira
c'abbia teoria lo prendono incastriamo
nella porta si incastrato nella porta mi
sa è incastrato no non so se si
incastrasse incassato che abbiamo
non si è incastrato sono due cosa sono
fermi sono fermi prova ad andare a
vedere che cosa c'è in quella stanza
vedere se agisco aspettano oggi
qualcos'altro
lanciamo dire le pietre non lo so magari
riusciamo a sopravvivere se sei tu e
molto giusto morendo di paura ci prova
porca [ __ ] stampando ricorrendo che
ora di sasha cori se c'è dell'acqua
bianche siamo salvi dell'acqua
dell'acqua dell'altro c'è un vicolo
cieco merda merda merda merda o persona
testa di quasi dell'acqua
oddio addio agli utili ci sono i box
carraie come bassa merda cioè l'acqua di
minchiata di mika stadi dichiarata che
alta e bassa cat merda
l'anno prossimo non ci arriva sta
sfondando tutto sta sfondando si arriva
cosa c'è dietro il the sun con ritocchi
come stai qua da quassù qua su questo
non ci arriva così non ci arriva da un
fucile obbligando che stanno in casa
l'ho colpito lo fa fitto
da quassù io lo colpiscono i nomi
colpisce perfetto ti vedo è dov'eri tu
dov'eri tu che c'era il bordino aveva
fatto sì el altro governo sparagli un
fresco era bravissimo no ha detto
attento a te sono due salsa
che cazzo di figata allora aspetta un
attimo figli della merda se sono
trovassi un modo per dargli fuoco
un flare noi vediamo meglio lo lancio ma
è del gennaio buttato giù io in teoria è
mica roba ma non era roba per dar fuoco
a loro aspetta fosse provata di persone
a roma per dar fuoco a ti ricordi che ci
avevi proiettili con l'arma del welafre
gun e la si può certo cioè rafer gun usa
la fiamma e mot uno è morto è morto è
morto
come ha fatto morire non lo so abbiamo
ucciso un po e sono morti tutti e due e
l'acqua sono fugati da soli abbiamo
ucciso due borse che si sono ammazzati
da soli nella pozzanghera sono morti o
si sono picchiati da se non lo so non ho
capito se abbiamo ucciso due boss non so
come abbiamo fatto
va bene se il palazzo cielo arrivati la
tv in un cunicolo cosa sono morti a so
non ci posso credere
no non ci posso credere non ha idea
d'acqua raga superare i 50 milioni
perché perdiamo questa roba solo michele
ma veramente mi piace accompagnano solo
qua ma ma quadrano fioccare come ho
fatto un'uscita guarda c'è qua c'è poi
puoi guardare attraverso miss ha trovato
un un'altra foto premier io ci sono rosa
uscire c'è un buco no se ti infine il
buco tipo indicare buco ma noi stiamo
noi stiamo facendo le cose dovremo fare
fatto trenta episodi è invece la stiamo
facendo adesso perché noi siamo forti
troviamo il pirellone duro o perché
scusami in questa porta c'era solo due
possono seconda davanti non aspetta via
questa parte sono arrivati guarda per
qualcos'altro di quasi ok
cos'è sta roba qua e poi scalare
qualcosa di piccone però non c'è niente
quindi non ha senso sicuro la roma è
chiuso non ha controllo ora controllato
aspetta abbia prima scalata che bello
fai vedere come scali che bello passa di
mano attaccare delle corde così sai
anche tu
non perché non posso risalire io no non
mi dire questo
allora mi posso senso riuscito sul sito
dove stai andando c'è una pietra o se
non ci ho capito ma che senso ha questo
scusami eh non ha senso
ok cosa c'è questo no sei tu guarda io
no niente ai suoi per scendere e solo
prescindere ma non ci della discesa
quindi non ho capito perché c'è qua
dentro non capito cosa sia questa stanza
non ho capito perché c'erano due boss
però vabbè arabi ci abbiamo preso un
piccolo cei sbagliato ma in realtà non è
sbagliato abbiamo fatto fuori dei boss
che probabilmente serviranno per finire
il gioco jack sparrow
allora accorge una pozzanghera
gigantesca io mi butto ci sei
stiamo aspettando prima che noi siamo
gli alma insiema simoni risusciti vado
vai è libero fino di cuore di una luce o
il riflesso si dovere anche tu la luce
rossa qui hanno lanciato un flyer anche
lì ma ti rendi conto che siamo un
partito con due ace schifose tutti due
box
ora che secondo me stimoli qua crolla
non se li lasci qualcosa
ecco ecco porca [ __ ] vedo esatto lo
vedi c'è un buco di merda
c'è qualcosa dall'altra parte devi
lanciare una dinamica e spaccare il muro
ecco perché lo vedi che c'è un buco
eccolo lì da tanto il catalano
io sempre le giunte da chiorda
ragazzuoli spero che viene sia piaciuto
è stato alquanto strano concludere così
ma continueremo nel prossimo episodio
che crei ora un avvio l'ansia tu mi stai
creando una nuova cosa nel mio corpo che
non avevo l'ansia lascia la paura io
stasera non dormo mai lasciato un vi
piace vi prego lasciatemi piace spero
che gli sono state veramente mi piace
vedere se dovessi si chiede che ci
vediamo prossimo video vice asha oggi
notre di telecomandati cazzone ai tre
bella ragazzi